linear DiCaprio obviously you guys go
back way back to Romeo and Juliet not me
the et was there covering that back in a
day do you think it's finally is here do
you think he deserves to win this year
absolutely the dude is the genius he's
been a genius for decades now and he's
not very old so yeah yeah no and no apps
such an exquisite actor and we've all
adored him and that yeah he's been he's
been under appreciated and in that kind
of formal you know blingy sense yes I
know you're here with your a handsome
husband I am is this on any level like a
sort of a date night for you guys you
guys can enjoy this oh yeah absolutely
yeah my sorry Smurfs on is with my
parents tonight and um yeah we get to be
grownups for a second it's nice talk a
little bit about you know homeland the
fact that it's such a fan favorite but
also being recognized by obviously your
peers and you know this show just it
really resonates with a lot of people
you mean yeah well it's um it's I credit
our writers with just being able to
anticipate what's going to be most
relevant
it's almost unnerving how how accurately
they can they can anticipate what's
going to be happening in the world